a couple months ago justice alito's
draft opinion that if it became a
decision when overturn roe v wade was
leaked and in the wake of that violent
activists have harassed justices at
their homes they've also targeted
pro-life groups more than 40 times there
have been dozens of attacks on churches
and pro-life pregnancy counseling
centers in recent months here's just a
sampling of them
if abortions aren't safe then you aren't
either that's just part of the message
outside wisconsin family action here and
it continues inside the building madison
police say it appears someone threw a
molotov cocktail inside the building
this building was up in flames this
morning when police and firefighters
arrived and this is the aftermath broken
windows shattered glass and graffiti ceo
jim hardin says this didn't come as a
complete shock recently compass care has
been receiving threats online and in
person the graffiti on the side of the
building says jane was here and hardin
says he thinks the abortion rights group
jane's revenge is behind the attack
well nancy pelosi who as she has told us
many times is very catholic was given a
chance to condemn these attacks which
seem to be very easy for any humane
person who believes in law and decency
instead here's what nancy pelosi said
there has been a number of attacks on
on churches on crisis pregnancy centers
republicans are
going after democrats for not saying
anything and they're saying that that
your rhetoric is contributing to these
attacks on these crisis
a woman has a right to choose to live up
to her responsibility it's up to her
her
doctor her family her husband her her
significant other and her god
i'm a very catholic person and i believe
in every woman's right to make her own
decisions
so how hard is it to say if you're
purportedly a christian and she claims
to be
throws it in your face in fact told us
several years ago that ms-13 were
children of god how hard is it to say
you know whatever you think about
abortion i'm for you're against defined
you can't attack churches and you can't
attack faithful christians because
they're christians but she couldn't say
that it shows you that she's not a
christian
she's a poser and in a better violence
victor davis hanson is a senior fellow
at the hoover institution he joins us
tonight uh professor thanks so much for
coming
kind of chilling that the speaker the
house can't just flatly condemn attacks
on churches
yeah i think there's two two messages
tucker the most immediate is deterrence
and i think when
you can get away with attacking pro-life
groups or you can swarm the houses and
that's a felony to do so
uh supreme court justices and intimidate
them or you can swarm a catholic diocese
and break in during a service and
there's no consequences that sends a
message and the message the left wants
to send is you better be careful because
the government is on our side and not on
your side and they're going to
selectively prosecute our arrest and
that's the message and it also empowers
our own people it emboldens them if we
get away with putting graffiti on a
person's
office or burning down what's the next
thing
the second message is i i i hesitate to
say this tucker but i don't think we're
we're a society that is ruled by law
we're in a revolutionary period right
now something like 18th century france
or 1920s russia
where the law is fluid and it's whatever
the power to be says it is so
if you're just to take some examples if
you're james o'keefe or you're peter
navarro or roger stone you're going to
have an fbi come down on you like you
don't know what
but if you refuse a you know a subpoena
like eric
holder did or if you lie uh to a federal
investigator like andrew mccabe did or
you lie under oath to the u.s congress
like both john brennan and james clapper
there's no consequences very little and
and so the law is uh
designed that on the premise that the
the noble
ends justifies any means necessary and
the left is this has
defined those means as radical equality
fairness social justice not
constitutional law
and so i think right now people are
really weird bizarre they see may 31st
2020 a mob from lafayette square tries
to torch down a historic church tries to
swarm on federal property the white
house grounds sends the president into a
bunker with his family and there's very
little consequences at gas compared to
january 6th
and so i think the law is very fluid
merrick garland is is much to blame so
is joe biden yes
it's part of the left ideology that's in
ascendance right now and it's very scary
because i think most americans realize
if you are of a particular political
persuasion and you break the law or
you're accused of breaking law you're
going to be treated very differently oh
very good
yeah stephen colbert is exalting in that
fact tonight big james hansen great to
see you thank you so much
thank you
subscribe to the fox news youtube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from tucker carlson
tonight